a change of scene but no escape from the
same set of problems a cabinet
get-together at the prime minister's
grace and favor Mansion the PM's
priorities and the party's election
prospects on the agenda but Rishi sunak
still stuck on an issue that's dogged
him for days
someone who's here today is Nadeem
zahawi do you have confidence in him
well it comes to Nadine's a hobby or
anyone else what I believe in is due
process and that's why I appointed an
independent advisor to look into the
questions that have been raised
investigate the situation fully
establish the facts and provide advice
to me hardly a ringing endorsement of
the man he made party chairman the Prime
Minister knows he needs to get back on
track fast Rishi sunak heard today that
there is just about a path to him
staying in Downing Street after the next
election providing pretty much
everything goes his way from here on in
but with the investigation into Nadine
zahawi's tax Affairs expected to last up
to another 10 days there's no sign yet
that his Premiership is having a
positive effect for the conservatives in
the polls
the tax settlement that threatens Mr
zahawi's political career did include a
penalty he says it was all a careless
not deliberate mistake the head of hmrc
in front of MPS today less sure there
are no penalties for innocent errors in
your tax Affairs so if you you know if
you take reasonable care but
nevertheless make a mistake whilst you
will be liable for the time for the tax
and for interest if it's paid late you
would not be liable for a penalty
Stratford upon Avon has been
conservative for decades but this is
Nadine zahawi's seat and frustrations
with the local MP and his party are
running high it's disgraceful you can't
put yourself into public life and
particularly be Chancey with Checker I
think he moves with whatever suits him
it's not right is it it's not right it
needs to come clean and just explain
himself really one rule for us and one
rule for those other people I think
that's what I think about I think it's
crazy Nadim zahawi has now given
permission for hmrc to share his private
tax details with his investigator in
here they claim to be waiting for due
process before judgment if you expect
the party chairman Will Survive Samco
Sky News